you get all these rural Mexicans who
hate the government hate taxes love guns
and love the Liberty to get as drunk as
they want perfect Republicans but the
Republicans will never know that today I
want to talk with you about the promise
of America we must change the decisions
we are making by changing the people who
are making them and that is why today
that is why tonight I am announcing that
I'm running for president of the United
States after I announced my candidacy
for president of the United States the
2016 presidential election is over a
year away but history is already being
made as two Hispanic candidates senators
Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz contend for the
Republican nomination for a party that
struggle to get just under 30% of the
Hispanic vote the last time around you
think this would be a good thing right
oh god that's Gustavo Ariano he writes
the ask a Mexican column for The OC
Weekly and is the author of the book
taco you essay how Mexican food
conquered America he thinks Rubio and
Cruz are the worst candidates
Republicans could pick to attract
Hispanic voters Ted Cruz first and
foremost I kind of feel bad for him
because people make fun of him for not
being able to speak Spanish but a lot of
people who are making fun of him for
that also can't speak Spanish so I have
some sympathy for the guy but he's just
I feel that people view him as being too
much of a walk to ever really be a big
present or to be a president on the
other hand Rubio is a great brown hope
for the GOP but this there's something
about him that Latinos just do not like
they like rub him the wrong way
he's like that that cousin that you
always hated on the one that was would
go to the quinceanera ass but would
never dance because he was kind of
looking at the side thinking it was all
that dressing is a little suit like a
little bit too preachy or like precious
for everyone's taste Rubio may come off
as precious but his Cuban roots could
also rub some Hispanic groups the wrong
way when I was growing up there was
always sign oh this is this underlying
disdain for community can you talk a
little bit about where that comes from
it's all going of guano yeah well the
Mexicans we love Cubans we love the
boxers without the baseball players we
love the singers been Imhotep a
desperado
sylia Cruz but when it
comes to the political side of the Cuban
American experience we despise it
because infamously the United States had
that wet foot dry foot policy where if
you were a Cuban and you somehow made it
into the United States it doesn't matter
what your background was you immediately
became a resident of of the United
States you would not be deported back to
Cuba on the other hand Mexico and
Mexicans for over a century we've been
coming here not only for jobs would also
fleeing violence in our homelands
whether it's nautical s or the Mexican
Revolution feel the fleeing economic
desperation and yet we were always
classified as illegal so you know
documented folks my dad he came to this
country the trunk of his Chevy he was
near his family was near death starving
in Mexico via droughts and all that yet
somehow he was not able to come into
this country legally but millionaire
Cubans were able to come in that was
just a cold war at its worst so Mexicans
will always have a chip on their
shoulder against Cuban politicians not
the Cuban people but Cuban politicians
specifically it's almost like Jeb Bush
has more Hispanic bona fides than the
two guys that are actually in the race I
mean do you think he would be able to
maybe harness that or do you see that as
authentic at all here's a dirty little
secret about the Bush's Mexicans loved
the Bush's George HW Bush whatever no
one really liked them but George W Bush
we like the fact that he came from Texas
we like the fact that he spoke a little
bit of Spanish we like the fact more
importantly that Bush got that w got
Mexican immigration when he said
undocumented folks are not evil they
have you know the famous family valleys
do not stop at the Rio Grande people
appreciated him then you have Jeb who
speaks better Spanish than Rubio he you
know his children half Mexican the
little brownies their little brown ones
as Barbara called them and this is a guy
who from the very beginning I said look
Mexican immigrants yeah I might not only
agree with illegal immigration but these
Mexicans who come we should respect them
and we should treat them as Americans as
what they are I mean he's even more
radical in his statements I would argue
than anyone in the Democratic side
definitely Hillary and even Obama but
that's why Jeb just does not stand a
chance because the right wing of the
Republicans are gonna eat him alive and
they're gonna side and you know Rubio
knows this Rubio was Jeb's protege and
now even he's turning to the right on
immigrant
I mean even you know I think the thing
that's turned a lot of younger people
off is his statements on the DREAM Act I
mean I mean when you run into a primary
like this you know saw what happened in
2012 it basically turned into a goat
rodeo just ridiculous things is there
any way that an immigration reform
minded person like Jeb could even make
it through ever for a Republican primary
there is no way someone who thinks of
Mexicans as human beings will win the
Republican nomination ever at least in
this generation so Jeb has no chance
Rubio my I still don't think I I
personally think Scott Walker ultimately
is going to get it because you know he's
just cutting you know he's cutting
things in Wisconsin left and right so
that's gonna appeal a little bit more to
the GOP base but what the Republicans
need to learn if they want to stay a
viable party that is they have to learn
shocking concept Mexicans are humans
undocumented people are humans and of
course what I've been saying for years
and years Mexicans actually especially
Mexicans recent generations they are
about as freedom-loving and liberally
loving as a group as you can get like
all you get all these rural Mexicans who
hate the government hate taxes love guns
and love the Liberty to get as drunk as
they want perfect Republicans but the
Republicans will never know that and
because in woe to those Republicans
though who don't pay attention though
Hispanics only make up about 10% of
voters today that number will double to
about 40 million in the next 15 years
and while libertarians get a bum rap for
being just a bunch of old white dudes
Pew Research Center found that Hispanics
lean just as libertarian as whites
so what's causing the shift young
Latinos like all young people hate both
the Democrats and the Republicans they
hate the Republicans because they
demonize Latinos they hate the Democrats
because they deport Latinos so there's
no way on earth we want to stay with any
of those parties and yes there's been a
long leftist tendency in the Chicano
Movement in just Latin America but this
idea of libertarianism has always
appealed especially to younger Latinas
who grew up like myself younger my dad
my uncles they all came to this country
without papers they made something of
themselves they made it without any
government hands out handouts
they're the ones who said don't rely on
the government for
anything just do it on your hard work
and make something of yourself I lean a
little bit more on the left libertarian
side than my cousins but my cousins they
would be perfect
rock-ribbed Republicans except again
when the Republicans start talking trash
on our on undocumented folks they start
saying that's my uncle you're talking
about that's me too I said yeah or me
Neil Santos that's my dad so screw you
for that and more importantly it's like
in this day and age what do young
Latinos want we don't want a drug war we
see what the war on drugs has caused in
Mexico in our ancestral land we see what
it's caused here in the United States
dirty cops we've been we've been arguing
about that since the Zoot Suit Riots
back in the 1940s and when you have
Democrats and Republicans standing by
these killer cops and saying oh we got
to do reform how are you gonna support
those parties you just can't at all so
there is that opening for libertarianism
to try to get more Latinos that way you
see Hispanics that identify that way bit
you know they vote Democrat anyway I
mean is that like the lesser of two
evils kind of unfortunately the way this
country is set up a lot of Latinos are
just voters in general they're gonna go
for the lesser of two evils but the
great thing at least from the younger
generation they're being more vocal
about it dreamers especially they've
done a magnificent job of just harassing
Obama Hillary especially Rubio they love
to antagonize Rubio so we're gonna see a
lot of that and the dreamer movement of
course comes from the left but they've
been great there's they're telling their
elders we're not going to vote blindly
for a Democrat just because they're a
Democrat we're gonna vote for a
candidate who actually is going to stand
with us and if you're gonna ignore us
what you know was to you how would you
approach the conversation on immigration
then so that it is a little bit more
humane and respectful what I've always
try to do in ask a Mexican is humor in
in though in the years since I've been
doing ask of Mexican I also try to talk
food because at the very lead as the you
know the line Americans hate Mexicans
but love Mexican food a couple years ago
I had a debate with Tom Tancredo the
former congressman from Denver very very
interesting guy we had a conversation
about immigration in the packed house
mostly Chicanos a lot of people who did
not like him at all it was a civilized
conversation and we agreed to disagree
but before all of that we broke tamales
at a restaurant right across the street
so it
all about having those conversations
we'll hear a lot of hot takes during
this election cycle about the importance
of the Hispanic vote but what exactly is
a Hispanic the term was coined by the
Census Bureau in the 1970s to cover
anyone who originated from
spanish-speaking countries but today
births within the United States are the
main drivers of growth in the Hispanic
population so what does it mean to be
Hispanic in 2015 the great thing for me
about a Latino identity is that you make
it what you want of yourself in the
earlier days even going back 90s to 2000
there was a very set checklist you you
could only call yourself a Latino of a B
and C now I mean some of the most
Chicano people I know are total 100%
Camacho's who get identified with
community activism with you know going
against killer cops with going against
the you the people trying to deport
undocumented folks yeah I would consider
them more Chicano then you know Mexican
children and Mexican immigrants but that
you know there's this great line for
that an artist once said that what was
it something like my definition of an
American is to be as Mexican as I want
so for me my definition of Latino is to
do call do whatever I want to do in this
country myself I'm the child of
immigrants from Zacatecas yet some of my
favorite music is Cambodian psychedelic
rock I freaked out over Vietnamese fun
bond me and all that my wife she's half
white half Mexican my favorite author is
John Steinbeck um you know I love the
cobs I know shoot me
but I get to choose that identity and or
sometimes what I say sometimes I feel
like a sock at econo sometimes I feel
like a Chicano sometimes I feel like a
Latino maybe once every five years a
Hispanic but I choose them click for
more and subscribe for all the latest
reason TV videos